The answer is yes.
In nearly all cases of mapping, we have robot uncertainty in motion.
That uncertainty might grow over time.
We need to address this; otherwise the map looks really bad.
Let me give an example .
Suppose a robot drives down a corridor, and it senses surrounding walls.
If this robot has a drift problem and because of uncertainty it its motion,
it actually believes it drives a trajectory like this.
Then the surrounding map would look very much like that.
Now, these might be indistinguishable at first glance,
but if this robot ever comes back to the same place,
then it has an opportunity to correct all this.
A good SLAM technique is able to understand not just the fact that the environment
is uncertain but also the robot itself runs on an uncertain trajectory.
That makes it hard.